who says I don't express my feelings hi
welcome to this video it's Friday you're
on the it's grace youtube channel so
let's comment on your in comments
expletives with no explanation ki jaya
thank god it's fun let's start over
maybe Rilke I'm a [ __ ] Facebook I do
not use it consistently or regularly the
revision Maya M Mafi new person new
person to person
alright this is part of this that just
happened naturally probably do not know
what a new person comments on my social
media I grace the crap out of them and
welcome them to the it's grace family
how do I know if it's a new person or
not how do we know anything in life how
do we know that this is real life and
we're not just all having a one
collective fever dream no one knows my
amalfi more like Maya
I'm awfully upset that your last name
sounds like a rejected eighth dwarf from
no way sleepy don't be happy sneezy
where's Muffy no one gives any it's
about Maffeo good at least we're all on
the same page let's go work in the coal
mines the most dangerous job for a
normal height adverse in' let's do this
you will grace they sell big more like
grace Helbig cry face laughing emoji cry
face laughing emoji sorry I love you
like wow that was an emotional
rollercoaster you got me good you don't
have to be sorry because I am a hell pig
stank like a pig same level of
intelligence like a pig and I'm probably
definitely going to help you nail it
tailored argax
new person uber
Merson tailored our cats more like
tailored dark yaks gotta hurt when you
fell from heaven because the Lord
rejected you because he said you did the
nasty nasties in the privacy of your own
bedroom and not the normal nasties the
two nasty nasty is to the point that the
gates of heaven were like no no your
grace this may not be a reliving post
but your facebook seems to have the
least amount of [ __ ] for you to weed
through true but I need to inform you
about the new Real Housewives franchise
Toronto huh also huh this is how I
imagine the Real Housewives of Toronto
would go down um excuse me sorry
I'm sorry what sorry I just um sorry I
just wonder I'm sorry sorry sorry all
right
I just I really wanted to just like
confront you about so sorry sorry I love
your shirt thank you so much sorry I'm
just staring at your chest because I
just I love your shirt oh sorry sorry
I'm not presenting them more so sorry
sorry I'm so sorry sorry sorry I cannot
wait let's go to toy driver Connor gage
thrash new person to person to person
Connor gage trash more like that sounds
like hot topic sponsored in American
Gladiator good there's no big gross
yourself challenge was lit ass I love
your video so much grace one thank you
to lit is this new thing that everyone
says and I know it means like whoa
that's lit like that's on fire like that
is cool which is interesting that we
celebrate fire as like a cool exciting
thing because I give it two house fire
you're like well this house fire is lit
but steel it's an acronym the state of
being so intoxicated regardless of the
intoxicating agent that all the person
can do is smile so that they look lit up
like a light oh he's so lit he can't
even talk pee
that's the example sentence what slit
extremely intoxicated last night I was
lit and I [ __ ] your sister
okay Daniel Sanchez new person to person
to person Daniel Sanchez more like damn
Daniel no wait no eject boom you've been
great yeah guys don't like my shirts
just came into today's the best hashtag
small youtuber look at your new look
wow you look like to Kylie Jenner's no
support Daniel if he's great Daniel I
cannot publicly say that I support you
because I haven't looked at your content
and I do not know if you're some sort of
raging racists but you look fun and
constantly candid and speaking of shirts
these are my new shirts that I'm selling
at represent accomplished it's grade six
available for the next two weeks
they say currently introverted can they
be any skink work here they could if
they came with pit stains already in
them oh that's a great idea
ah Urban Outfitters probably already did
it now let's go to you two
glad said new person to person to person
glad set more like glad that's not here
because she is so French
Subaru's both thinks that Grayson that
makeup looks a bit like Michael Jackson
Jack Ross new person a person Jack Ross
more like Michael t.j.maxx Ruben gross
WTF happened to grace she looks like a
cross between a cross dresser and
Michael Jackson okay you know I always
thought that my brand would evolve
online I just never saw it evolving into
this direction
blue phoenix new pooper scoopers and
blue phoenix more like that love when a
phoenix rises from the urges yuma gross
drops for eating the burst part of that
banana a couple people were very
concerned that I did or might eat
bruised part of the banana in last
week's Friday re and you not do that
let's this is education there are also
plenty of ways to cover up the mushy
consistency of bruised fruit there's
little risk to your health
in just eating it say you can eat the
bruised part of a banana and so you know
what you guys can eat eat it don't okay
that's it for commenting on your
comments this week I hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you haven't
already one go check out electro man and
Dyna girl it is out globally for
everyone go to Electra woman Dyna girl
calm and you can find out how you can
get it in your country also too if you
are interested in it currently
introverted baseball tee they are at
represent calm such it's grace sick so
link will be in the description they
come in four different colors and look
they're of a letter so you could if you
wanted to color them in or draw in and
personalize the t-shirt for yourself
love giving you guys work to do and
three subscribe to this channel if you
haven't yet because that's just you know
really great another than that I don't
know down how big new person-to-person
you're putting an Alan Helmick more like
just are we related if we're not related
more like Alan he'll pig you've been
great electric Dinah doodling for
something in heart o as electro one and
Dyna girl the movie is killer whoa
doodle is really good a doodle doesn't
sound like a good enough word to
describe what that is it I was looking
are you described an adorable dog oh
look it's a doodle but this is a doodle
Wow doodle doodle doodle doodle doodle
doodle doodle doodle doodle doodle free
sorry